as you guys know we've tried over and
over again to simona rehab and the
biggest headline to come out of that was
actually true but when she finally
decided to go to rehab
mama opened up a lot more than expected
all right miss june so this is cody
intake coordinator all right he's gonna
take it for me hey miss June I'm Kareem
oh nice I'm the case manager over here
so nice to meet you Miriam I'm doing
just fine if you'd like to take a seat
um I'm gonna walk you through our intake
process okay the intake here at this
addiction center will ask you 5,000 man
questions to be honest what you got
what's your do see if you don't mind me
asking I'm hard to be cooking Craig yeah
okay lost my vision and then I quit and
then I went to using just uh just
smoking crack it's weird because you
snorted winner
hey guys I've been here behind your eyes
get that how frequent were you doing
crap daily during the heaviest period
what was the amount that you use per day
a couple ounces okay by yourself yeah
okay yeah I mean seriously light shoot I
mean she don't have it was like three
grand a day
ya know you can go through some crack
pretty fast yeah because because I mean
what's so bad is I mean you're doing it
throughout the day and staying up you
know I'm saying I mean I could go
through a couple hours a day oh yeah
easy like no I don't even think about it
do you think that you need help to deal
with your alcohol or your drug use no if
I'm fully Indian one of the drugs then
I'm will jump right in but then again if
I choose that I don't want to do it I
don't do it she's an addict mama is a
real good habitual liar she tries to
convince everybody that she's telling
the truth that she can just go out and
quit drugs in your own that's not how
this works I mean my opinion is if she
doesn't need help to stop don't why
doesn't she just saw
who are you living with before you came
to treatment meow boyfriend I'm living
with him now I'm freezing going oh damn
and his patient facility huh
does he still actively use no but we've
both been clean for three months people
don't seem to believe that but okay so
we're not around you don't know that
yeah no I only have what you tell me
people I mean I'm sure I'm sure within
your friends circle or your family
circle that people doubted you at times
but it certainly happened it's really
happening at least in my own experience
I couldn't necessarily blame them yeah
how's your use of alcohol or drugs
affected your work in any way to me it
don't read in ya'll quit filming us
because I checked myself out of read so
I would say that it's it's maybe had
like kind of a significant impact on
your work substance abuse yeah I mean
but I don't I don't know I'm not getting
back together I get mad about that
situation but okay
[Music]